qué es el tema principal de todo acerca
de la unidad de cómo restaurar la
situación en eeuu requiere unidad
requiere unir al país mira al país como
una nación y a su vez por un lado el
tema de la unidad de estar juntos para
restaurar y cuando dijo restaurar es
restaurar o sea escribió todas las
políticas sobre las que él piensa actuar
como por ejemplo nombró el tema de la
pandemia a superar la pandemia abrir
escuelas que nombró el tema de la
economía los trabajos que se perdieron
la inequidad la justicia racial en
génova que es un tema que no va a ser
diferido más en esta situación el
crecimiento de la supremacía blanca el
terrorismo doméstico el cambio climático
salud para todos creo que el paso a paso
fue creciendo todos los componentes de
su política
los próximos 100 días al menos y por
otro lado enfatizando que esas políticas
todos se van a alcanzar con un eeuu
unidos unió noel cuando junto para no
para no fracasar se dio el respiro a dos
creo que este tipo de del el lenguaje
que usó fue un lenguaje de unidad